this past weekend was filled with tons
of blatant distraction and the
understandable focus was on the tragic
shooting at the Santa Fe Texas school we
had endless replays of the Royal Wedding
total waste of time
tons of people totally missed the story
about the second Trump Tower meeting
Trump tweeted over the weekend about how
he's gonna order the Justice Department
to investigate spying on the Trump
campaign by an Obama plant for example
tweeting quote I hereby demand and will
do so officially tomorrow that the DOJ
look into whether or not the FBI or DOJ
infiltrated or surveilled the Trump
campaign for capital P political
purposes and if any such demands or
requests were made by people within the
Obama administration and it got a ton of
attention you then had the commentary
about Trump's tweet from right-wing
media for example Fox News's Maria
Bartiromo
totally off the rails but Trump is
loving it a tweet from Fox News quoting
Maria Bartiromo is saying it sounds like
either President Obama or Hillary
Clinton were sort of masterminding all
of this and at the end of the day
between it being the weekend and the
right-wing media distraction machine and
the school shooting a ton of people
either never heard about the second
Trump Tower meeting or disregarded it is
not a big story and I need to make sure
that the story is out there and that
it's understood and what we know we knew
about the first Trump Tower meeting
right with the Kremlin connected Russian
lawyer
Natalia vessel Metz kaya the quid pro
quo was discussed dirt on Hillary to
help Trump in exchange for easing
Russian sanctions Don junior was there
Paul Manafort was there gyre kushnir was
there the gang was there right we now
know of a second meeting which was
broken by the New York Times involving
Trump jr. who seems to always be there
with an Israeli specialist and media
manipulation an emissary for two Arab
Prince's from Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates and a Republican
donor named Eric Prince who at this
point you probably are familiar with
because he is the guy from such
disasters as being the founder of the
Mersenne
a firm formerly formerly known as
Blackwater now it has some totally
innocuous name like I think it's Academy
with an eye or something like that
he's also the brother of Trump Secretary
of Education Betsy DeVos this meeting
opens up entirely new possible quid pro
quos possible violations of the
emoluments clause from this thing we
call the Constitution was the Israeli
embassy move connected to this meeting
in exchange for help was pulling out of
the Iran deal part of some quid pro quo
with a Saudi or Emirati Prince maybe we
just have no idea right now and I want
to remind everybody the steel dossier
this was implied in the steel dossier I
mentioned this line in the Trump Russia
dossier last week when we were talking
about the 500 million bucks for a Trump
linked project from China in Indonesia
at the same time that Donald Trump all
of a sudden tweeted he wants to help a
Chinese company get more jobs the line
from the dossier alleges that a source
close to Trump suggested that the
Republican campaign team was happy to
have Russia in the media spotlight as a
bogeyman or boogeyman I don't actually
know in this particular case which it is
could be both in fact to mask more
extensive corrupt business ties to other
countries is Saudi Arabia one of those
countries is Indonesia one of those
countries the United Arab Emirates once
again every indication that this meeting
might be part of that and these could be
examples of conspiracy to commit
election fraud and this story which
didn't receive nearly enough attention
may actually be the explanation for why
Trump went completely off the rails on
Twitter on Sunday of course he might
have learned about something we just
haven't heard about yet always a
possibility but when you look at these
erratic and aberrant tweets it often is
coinciding with wanting to at least
implicitly cover up bad news and it
actually worked here and he was helped
sadly by the Santa Fe shooting and a lot
of people just not hearing about this
second meeting yeah maybe because it
direct it release Warren directly to the
Russia stuff I mean I know you pointed
out the Christopher steel dossier
connection there but it doesn't have
that same lie and cover-up aspect that's
what the rest of this Russian narrative
has had over the past years that may be
part of it I mean every element made it
so that a lot of people just didn't hear
about the story including just the
timing of when it came out and my
question to you is is there anything
Trump criticized Hillary Clinton of
doing that he's not guilty of himself
that's the question I'm wondering about
right now you can send me your thoughts
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is also
on twitter at david pakman show today's
episode of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by Cody which is an
innovative new cryptocurrency and online
payment platform that is setting out to
revolutionize how we send and receive
online payments the same way that the
transportation industry has been
innovated by ride-sharing apps the same
way that music and video distribution
have been revolutionized by real-time
streaming Cody says that the payment
industry is ripe for transformation
right now Cody stands for currency of
the internet and they're setting out to
make their cryptocurrency which was
designed specifically to be used for
payments that will be the first crypto
if they succeed used on a widespread
mainstream basis for online payments
this will be payment system that can be
used by anyone whether you're a consumer
or a business and regardless of the
industry that you're in most cryptos
fail to meet the everyday needs of
average consumers or businesses and many
crypto currencies just weren't built
with convenient and trustworthy payment
as they're sort of primary function and
this is the specific niche that Cody is
trying to fill with the technology that
they've created if you're watching this
on youtube you can find out more about
Cody and their ICO in the links below
the video this is not financial advice
and you should do all of your own
research before making any investment
decisions